pivot toujours dos rond dans l'épisode 4
de ce nautic astroparticules et se
voulait rien dire c'est pas trop je
dédie à tous monde c'est c'ui du cjd la
table les rondes c'est easy nul les amis
on s'entend 3,6 dans l'eau pourquoi
parce que ça fait déjà une heure que je
suis sur le jeu est effectivement ma
sauvegarde avait été supprimé ça fait
toujours plaisir du coup j'ai fermé
comme un gros fils de [ __ ] juste pour
avoir ceci voilà et la combinaison
antiradiations qu'on avait mis tout un
épisode a chopé alors là on a un
objectif extrêmement simple on veut
construire la bea véhicules savez ce qui
permet de construire les vaisseaux sous
marin dans lesquels on peut aller
hyperpro fourie rencontrer des créatures
hyper vilaine
le fait est que maintenant il faut
scanner des espèces de blocs pour
pouvoir construire la bea véhicule
mobile
du coup oui vous l'avez deviné on va
essayer de trous amélie ferraille pourri
c'est vrai du coup va essayer de trop en
fait
ces [ __ ] de blocs voilà il ya une
signature thermique l'inquiéter repêché
parce que cg drôlement envie d'y aller
seulement sans vaisseau on va crever
c'est sûr donc on en est là voilà si
vous voyez un blog vous me le dites dans
le coin de l'oreille real et je retire
une oreille comme ça je vous entendrez
ya pas de soucis diolot exploration
total j'ai deux piles pour recharger le
sig ou et voilà elle est le sigle petit
jeu de mots à 6 se dire mr ces photos là
des menottes là ici un truc à scanner
mon gars c'est sûr regardez le ca tenant
sa non ya pas un truc à scanner mon gars
s'il vous plaît où va la bea véhicules
[ __ ] y'a rien c'était un piège c'est
un guet-apens
ça ressemble à des frigos les blocs on
dirait des frigos des gros frigo et lui
on peut le scanner ou penser est ce que
le manque de respect le scan assez
génial comme lui manque de respect quoi
cette pauvre bête à ya aussi un truc
dans ces games qui est assez fantastique
c'est que il ya seront minerai ya pas un
[ __ ] de mines raymond gamez vraiment
attaquer choix scanner ici attention au
oui ça ça c'est ce qu'annonce à
équipements de laboratoire je m'en bats
les couilles à ça permet de respirer je
savais pas c'est nouveau ça merci le
corail cerveau ventes à six paquets
nantes et caen et cerveau mais [ __ ] il
y avait un gros cerveau ça ce scam sa
poubelle mais je m'en fous des poubelles
joseph mois où il se passe quoi la faim
qui souffre comme ça
on met ça fait du faux mais ça bloque
pas bon gars et du minerai là c'est un
cratère peut pas y a pas un truc hyper a
ramassé jornal da brat ok je me tiens je
me tire ça un volcan sous marin
ça dégage mais c'est pas possible que
les héros fragments de machin analyser
et 0 minorer les gars tout moment où
l'animal est une société kaba regardez
pas du minerai dans cette grotte c'est
une grotte à minerai ça hein pourquoi
pas mais ne réussit pas parce qu'on est
dans une gamme de merde
écoutez après 20 minutes de recherche
qui n'ont abouti à rien du tout je suis
tombé sur ce site qui te donnes
l'endroit où il faut aller chercher les
fragments à scanner pour construire tel
ou tel truc ne faut qu'on trouve hui
frag ont toutes trois pour construire la
baie de véhicules là et 5 pour
construire le symop cela ils sont à
laquelle forest et les autres au gras si
plate et aussi il me semble que c'est
ici vaches et qu'il y en a deux en a une
la une un peu plus loin on va voir on va
chercher on va chercher à charge c'est
ça regarde et attend mais qu on
reconnaît là je partirai pas d'ici tant
que je vois pas trouver ces [ __ ] de
fragments d'âme et sa possible de
trouver ces fragments là c'était pas si
dur avant que ce soit des véhicules mon
gars bon bah écoute et vous savez quoi
on va en fait il ya deux endroits où il
ya des fougères là comme là-bas y avait
là en été il y en avait ici on va aller
à celle ici et si on trouve pas violeau
au mont dieu alors là fragments d avis
aux mondieux oh mon dieu je chiale plus
que deux eaux aux mondieux annoncera
gambas bio à 400 sont fous aux eaux
alors là c'est le graal
et je ne parle pas de la dernière
chanson de kyo à mon gars joris van camp
david et ola dessus tellement c'est le
mot le plus épique de la vidéo justement
on a trouvé le craft pour faire ce qu'on
veut faire depuis 10h alors tourner à la
base on va voir ce qu'il nous faut pour
faire la baie un véhicule et en surf à
retrouver les cinq fragments pour faire
lever aux aurores
alors pour la faire il nous faut l eua
lago titane du lubrifiant et une
batterie haute capacité lubrifiants ont
là me demandez pas pourquoi et le
lingots de titane ont là aussi on fait
maintenant on le fait maintenant ram ça
t'en bouche un coin beaucoup allez hop
c'est parti on enchaîne et quand je
disais qu'on l'avait c'est pas une
blague
regardez j'avais fait des petits stocks
avant de tourner mais ouais c'est ça
suivra youtuber exceptionnel mais a vécu
mobile
et ben voilà on y arrive à temps c'est
dix fois plus dur qu'avant pékin de
construire des choses à déployer la bd
là tu ne dis pas ce que je dois faire
déploie toi huawei juste à côté
missing blueprint ça veut dire qu'on a
pas encore scanner les cinq fameux
fragments c'est parti
ces housses et je sais où ces papas août
et pourquoi je dis ça mais avant en fait
on va manquer d'oxygène au ski va
falloir qu'on fasse extrêmement simple
c'est construire un truc nouveau je sais
pas ce que ça donne soif r les fameux
tuyaux de merde qu'on avait fait là un
peu pourri soit faire la poche d'air
qu'est ce que c'est je suis sûr c'est
une grosse connerie non poche d'air je
lé là là je fais clic droit
ça me fait remonter à la surface mais
c'est fantastique mais ç'a failli
déraper pendant que ça s'est fait avec
ça on va essayer de choper
moi ce que je jouais au passé le fil
d'ariane se fixer un point physique se
déroule que vous explorez ok on va faire
ça on va kraft et le fil d'ariane et on
va la tâche et à la béa véhicule mobile
super plan ça c'est moi qui coupe la
vigne ok ok les amis on est bon un nom
j'ai pris des grès de ses échantillons
qu'il faut [ __ ] arrêté couple au
hockey alors amusez pas que je peux pas
faire ce [ __ ] tout je pète un câble ou
et monsieur ok on va ramasser note b
faut pas la prendre je peux pas la
prendre mais non aux sports écoutez on
va prendre ça voilà on a pris on a pris
une caisse ont la tâche sera la moins
perméable toujours une solution de
secours à huawei fouette bricoleur dans
une optique a donc assez lent était tout
à l'heure on est tombé sur vraiment ce
qu'on peut appeler un [ __ ] de miracle
et je crois que c'est juste après cette
zone là la zone beaucoup plus profonde
où il ya les espèces de trucs bleus le
lithium d'oussalah voilà je pense que
c'est par là c'est là ou pas à l'eau
là-bas je vois des débris c'est la
petite banque c'est là
mes amis je suis un peu fatigué pourquoi
fatigué parce que j'arrive dans la game
il ya aucun [ __ ] minerai est ce le
problème c'est que sans cuivre 1
on peut pas faire d'objets qui émet de
la lumière que ce soit pour charger ce
[ __ ] de truc où cette lampe torche du
coup la nuit bas je suis bloqué jeu
juste enfants plus haut total dans un
coin je ne peux rien faire sans déconner
ça fait une heure une heure que je nage
mon gars ça fait une heure je cherche la
zone jean pls ok peut-être que c'est par
la mecque c'est l'une des rares zones
que j'ai pas explorer on va voir ça
ensemble et si c'est par là mon gars on
hurle de joie oh [ __ ] ça doit être par
là en fait la zone ne la reconnaîtra
puisque à des sortes de cheveux par
terre hockey le sol a des cheveux oh oui
oh oui oh oui au début de cheveux là mon
gars oui on y est c'est la sela truc
c'est que c'est entre 60 et 120 mètres
ça va être chaud on va avoir très peu de
temps pour trouver mais on va trouver
mon gars clic droit pour fixer sa au sol
hop ça sert à quoi j'ai pas trop compris
à quoi ça sert mais on va quand même
l'utiliser celle là [ __ ] c'est
formidable on a trouvé on va sauvegarder
immédiatement allé y a plus qu'à trouver
le spot wi a plein de frigo et là mon
pote on est les rois
allez va bien avoir un truc avec sans
déconner mais non sans mentir excuse moi
est ce que tu aurais pas vu un [ __ ] de
ces deux frigos genre samsung ou bosch
ou siemens
non j'en ai marre on est tellement
profond à les loups l'entrée via une
entrée ne mentez pas je le sais [ __ ]
sans déconner où est cette entrée bordel
de merde mais lyon va manquer on va
crever on va crever c'est quoi ça c'est
quoi ok j'ai ouvert ça et ça fait quoi
encore une autre porte [ __ ] mais y'a
rien j'ai plus l'air avant d'ouvrir des
portes
cet homme n'avait rien c'était dans
leurs dix huit années plus tard on en
est toujours elle put 1 2
si je peux me permettre cette fois j'ai
trouvé un peu de fric donc maintenant
d'aller plus dans notre sigle aïda on va
un peu plus vite
mes amis aujourd'hui est un grand jour
puisque enfin le psy motte vient de
finir sa construction et on a un [ __ ]
de choix après 1h30 2h que dis-je
d'explora à chanter en train de le
chasser
[ __ ] de merde bref on est pas mal on
est payé 6 47% nathan il en plastique le
sibot sans déconner du coup on va aller
voir ce qu'il y avait à la signature
thermique là bas et ça vole quand est ce
autre chose on ne sait pas aïe aïe aïe
c'est le lay voilà ce qui reste de notes
au belge tient pas sa venue sur ce no
jikan n'hésitez pas à les aimer ça vous
a pu écouter le jeu a bien changé il ya
beaucoup de trucs qu'avant et je trouve
que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué maintenant tu dois scanner des
fragments pour construire quoi que ce
soit par exemple on compte un truc qui
kiffe et spawn des véhicules
eh bien il faut trouver cinq fragments
qui sont hyper profond donc tu peux pas
y aller avec un véhicule puisque du coup
et ben t'as pas encore guéri fragments
enfin bref où j'étais très fébrile à sur
cette explication du coup ouais on voit
qu'ils y mettent l'exploration en avant
et qui en outre qu'un petit peu plus dur
mais je trouve ça pas forcément génial
enfin bon le jeu est quand même très
très bon après ce maintien et on a
construit le simone
à partir de là tout va bien à xiii a
procédé au maire cela vous regarde et
portez vous bien tout le monde puisse
oh